it's make or break for the Golden Globes
welcome to the nomination announcements
for the 80th annual Golden Globe awards
after a series of scandals and a
scrapping of the annual broadcast last
year please join us for Hollywood's
party of the year on Tuesday January
10th the embattled award show is putting
efforts towards a comeback starting with
the 2023 nominations here it was covered
the 85-member group had no black members
a part of their organization in 2021 the
LA Times blasted the Golden Globes
outing their lack of inclusivity and
diversity sparking a major boycott many
celebrities took part including Tom
Cruise who returned his three statues
boycott was led in Hollywood by the top
talent and PR agencies to boycott the
Golden Globes and not have any
participation in their show best Motion
Picture drama and today Tom became a
nominee again top gun Maverick he could
still
be in attendance at the ceremony but I
think there's still more work to do
after pledging change and a year off air
the Golden Globes will be returning to
NBC in January when it comes to the pr
firms that led the boycott where they
stand today is they do recognize that
there are some steps that have been
taken by the hfpa but they want to see
more back in November Brendan Fraser
told GQ he would not participate in the
upcoming ceremony despite being
nominated for best actor today Brendan
Frazier has said publicly that he will
not and he's considered the front-runner
for elite actor drama for his
performance in the whale
as for the shows that were selected for
their outstanding work Abbott Elementary
is leading the TV category with five
nominations including best actress for
Quinta Brunson one last one for the road
well Zendaya has taken home two
Primetime Emmy wins for her role in
Euphoria the actress has landed her
first cloak knob when I first met her I
was just
[Music]
Michelle yo and Margot Robbie nabbed the
best actress nomination while Angela
Bassett is up for best supporting
actress for black panther wakanda
forever
[Music]
while Rihanna was also nominated for her
best original song from Black Panther
Lift Me Up she'll be up against Taylor
Swift for her song Carolina from where
the crawdads sing and while she may be
the only woman in her category Canadian
Sarah Polly grabs a non for best
screenplay for women talking Seth Rogen
is also on the list nominated for best
supporting actor